as we celebrate Title IX Title Nine
Title Nine I wouldn't be here if it
wasn't Title Nine is super important for
the future of women's sports I think
it's contributed to absolutely every
girl and every woman that has played
collegiately and at every single level I
don't know a world without it and what
that means is I don't know a world
without opportunity
it's about equality it's about you know
giving the boy and the girls the same
opportunities and just watch and see
what we can do with those opportunities
for young girls like myself to be able
to play and love the game of sport that
we're in today
her rise because she is never done
[Applause]
Los Angeles are you ready for her rise
I'm pepper parsley and I couldn't be
more excited to be here with y'all today
everybody ready to have some fun
all right I want to introduce you to our
host Anne moderator for the day she's an
actress model musician and just recently
joined the Las Vegas Raiders is in-game
host give it up for simply schools
what's up everybody
okay so before I do anything this is
what I always do before I do an event
first of all thank you Los Angeles thank
you Nike for all of us being here today
pepper come up here next to me we have
to make sure everyone's pulse is going
and they're alive and breathing and
excited to be here right yeah so on the
count of three everybody buddy can we
get some noise in here ready one two
three
here we go
okay I'm excited to be here La the sun
is shining the sky is bright and
beautiful you all look amazing so thank
you for being here on behalf of Nike
today is all about how we as girls and
women rise through Sport and I couldn't
think of a better place for that
conversation than right here with all of
you we've got the LA Sparks just right
around the corner a few locks to the
left the Bank of California Stadium
where the Angel City FC play and these
are all places where dreams are being
made every single day and listen we've
come a long way
but 50 years isn't that long ago right I
know a lot of you here are probably they
have parents or grandparents who were
alive 50 years ago I know I do and
things change in the blink of an eye and
50 years is a span of time where a lot
can happen but a little over 50 years
ago there were scientists and doctors
get ready for this
who thought that women couldn't
physically run a marathon or they would
literally die how is how do they think
that exactly we know that's not true
right yes we know exactly thank you
um but listen we've obviously proved
everyone wrong this year marks 50 years
since a law called Title IX came into
play it was a landmark bill that
enforced gender equity in high school as
well as Collegiate Sports once and for
all so let's give it up for Title Nine
for a second
since then I want to give you some
submission rates of women in College
college sports went from seven percent
jumped all the way up to 40 percent so
we have to really soak it in right now
and realize how far we have come but
listen we all know this that's sitting
here right now progress is never done
and there's still so much work to do
so now it is time for us to look forward
to the next 50 years and decide how
we're going to use our grit our grind
and our hustle to channel the
Revolutionary women who came before us
and Elevate Sport and play for all of
the girls and women that are out there
today we're coming together to talk
about it so we can be about it I know
that's right so we are here today guys
Pepper take it away and we are not only
doing it for ourselves we're doing it
for each other and the next generation
of girls coming up next and we're doing
this together there's just something
about girls and women in sports we love
to support and uplift each other it's so
beautiful and strong you said it now
again before we get this started this
conversation we want you all to enjoy
yourselves I want to see some smiles and
love in this room so again how are we
feeling in Los Angeles
okay
so pepper let's let them know today
we're going to have conversations with
women on the front lines of creating
change in sport some who have made
change in the past some who are
currently making change today and some
who are rolling up their sleeves like
all of you sitting here to redefine what
sport looks like for you your community
and of course the Next Generation so I
don't know about all of you but I'm
looking forward to this to looking
around this room right now and I can see
and feel the love and support I know I
keep asking you to get involved and get
loud and excited but it feels really
good to be standing up here especially
next to Pepper I've been stalking her
Instagram and seeing all of her
interviews and she's amazing
um listen whether we're playing for fun
or we're playing for medals I've seen
all of you out on that fun run we're
about to empower each other now today in
this room by supporting each other
helping each other to Rise Up The
Sisterhood of sports starts when we're
young of course and as young children we
look to strong female role models in our
family in elementary school we're
looking to the Junior High kids Junior
High kids are looking to the high
schoolers and then the high schoolers
are looking up to the college kids and
we're all looking up and being inspired
by Elite athletes for those women rising
to the top of their game they're not
only doing it for themselves but they're
doing it for all of us so this club
where we all help each other out it is a
good one absolutely thank you for all of
that sib and here to talk about how we
Empower each other as women in sport we
are joined by the youngest woman to win
an Olympic snowboarding gold medal at
the age of 17. give it up for Chloe Kim
foreign
winner of 20 summer paralympic medals
and one Winter paralympic medal Tatiana
McFadden
hello how are you
and L.A Bruins very own top soccer
scorer a sophomore forward on the UCLA
women's soccer team and Nike's first U.S
college student athlete sponsorship give
it up for Rayland Turner yeah
oh okay should we take a seat let's do
it let's get comfortable ladies hello
how are you feeling today good good see
these are the smiles I like to see
everyone's got their teeth out and
smiling and happy we've gotta talk
there's so much to cover today
um I want to start off with something
that basketball legend Lisa Leslie once
said we all stand on the shoulders of
others even when you're six foot five uh
can each of you tell us about a moment
when you realize you were standing on
the shoulders of those who came before
you
yeah
um you know for I'm sorry thank you so
much for having me here I'm really
excited to be here um title uh nine has
been such a pivotal moment um for women
in sports but especially for people with
disabilities and I've had to fight for
equal access just to participate on my
high school track team and so I came
home from the paralympic games in Athens
with a silver and bronze to my name and
I couldn't be an equal member of my high
school track team and so I knew that
wasn't right and the person who helped
me were not only my wonderful parents
who believed that I could win this fight
but actually a paralympic athlete
Chantal Petty Claire who is a Canadian
athlete and she fought for rights in in
Canada for equal opportunities for for
paralympic athletes and so we we won
that lawsuit for and we sued for no
money no damages but for the right for
people with disabilities to be
participated in high school sports
equally and so she's been such a great
mentor and anything that I want to do
and set my mind to
my parents and her have been such a
great support
absolutely can you just emphasize on
that before I go back to you ladies for
a second because I do want to talk about
Title IX it's so important and again
that's what we're celebrating for 50
years and we have so much more work to
do can you just talk on the work that
can be done moving forward to help in
that because a lot of people also didn't
know what Title IX was there are some
people out there who did not know yeah
so I mean Title IX we're here for we're
celebrating women's and women's sports
and and the equality but it's also been
so important for for people with
disabilities Title IX has been such a
huge movement I mean not only in schools
but jobs and
um opportunities and right now I'm still
fighting for equal rights in our sport
in the paralympic movement in the
Marathon Community competing in the
paralympic games this year in Tokyo was
the first time that we got paid equally
and I've been in this sport for
[Applause]
and I've been in the sport for 16 years
and there's been such an incredible
um and pay Gap and so that's why I've
been so thankful to my sponsors and what
Nike has done for for the movement of
women in sports is absolutely incredible
and for people with disabilities in the
paralympic community to be part of it is
is huge because if you have a body you
can be an athlete and so that's that's
huge absolutely thank you thank you for
letting us know about that yeah
[Applause]
um ladies again whoever wants to chime
in on this one did you where was the
time that you actually realized that
young women were also looking up to you
how you were looking up to women before
you
for me it's actually kind of crazy to
think that there are young girls out
there who look up to me
um because I was that girl and I still
am you know even being in this room
today
um with all these other incredible
female athletes and how inspired I am
every time I'm here and I'm so grateful
for Nike for giving us this space to be
able to share our stories and continue
continue to inspire others
um but no it's so crazy to me just
because again I was that girl I was that
girl that always looked up to other
amazing female athletes and hoping that
one day I could get there but also
acknowledging that they fought a very
hard fight
for equality and to be seen and get the
same amount of support that a lot of men
do in their Sports
um even for me growing up you know I
started doing Pro level competitions at
13 and a lot of the times no one would
show up to watch our final contest but
for the men everyone would be there and
watching that change over the years
seeing how much more support we do get
now at these events is honestly been so
incredible to watch and so honored to be
part of that and I'm really excited for
the future of women's sports because of
that
absolutely did you want to add on to
that yeah
you know like Chloe said it's crazy to
think that you know people like us have
that impact on kids how other people
have had the impact on us and for me
really the first time where it really
hit me was a family friend or my mom's
friend's daughter who's probably five
years old she it was Jersey day at her
school and she was like oh I want to be
raelyn Turner and she had UCLA stuff on
and she had Nike stuff on and it really
like it worn my heart and it made me
take a step back and say wow like I I
can be that person that kids look up to
and see them as oh I can achieve my
goals like that's who I want to be and
it's it's just crazy like you guys have
said to think that we can have an impact
on the Next Generation yeah
all right and Chloe you've spoken
honestly about the pressure of success
in the high stakes involved in Elite
Sport what would your advice be for
girls who love sport but are anxious
about failing
this is a tricky one to answer because I
think I'm still trying to figure this
out myself but um you know it's hard
it's such a blessing that I get to do
what I love for a living and have all
this incredible support by Brands like
from Brands like Nike but um you know
it's not always pretty and I think a big
part of my journey has just been being
open about it I'm looking at this Banner
that says talk about it but yes like
talk about it because
you know I think a lot of people I
always felt like everyone expected me to
be perfect because I was perfect when I
was snowboarding I that was the one
thing I was so confident and comfortable
doing but it felt like the rest of my
life was falling apart
um and I was so afraid to just deal with
that and come to terms with it and so
you know never lose your love for
you know your thing what you love to do
for me it's snowboarding never lose your
love for that and in doing so you know
sometimes you have to take a step back
from that I'm taking a step back from
snowboarding for a bit because I went
there crazy season with the Olympics and
everything but just
just take that step back you know take a
break reset and um
start all over again I guess would be
the best piece of advice but I've just
been out hanging out enjoying LA it's
hot here spending quality time with my
family just really going back to the
roots you know I think it keeps you
grounded and helps you mentally quite a
bit
um for you Raymond I know Sports is uh
it's a strong community that you grew up
around and again having family members
look up to you or young kids just look
your way how has it empowered you to be
the woman and athlete that you are to
this day
um I mean gosh I think I can speak for
all of us when I say
um if it weren't for sports we wouldn't
be the people we are today I wouldn't be
sitting here
um Sports has been such a big part of my
life my mom played soccer through
college my dad was in the NFL my older
sister plays soccer
we just that has kind of built the
person I am today I'm competitive
all of my friends really that I have are
through Sports
and um Sports have taught me so many
different things so many life lessons
they have helped me with accountability
discipline
um
and sort just all sort of things in life
it's just really important to kind of
surround yourself with people who are
like-minded people who have similar
goals and
um
yeah without Sports I don't know what I
would do
but um yeah and then having a community
not only you know like friends but
having a community built around your
sport that can connect you with
other communities I mean I'm sitting
here right now with people who I
probably wouldn't know without soccer
but um
yeah I think that
Sports although
it's kind of you see it in a certain way
it can also be dissected in a way that
it's like oh like it's not just about
winning
um it builds your life around Sports and
it shows you that you know you can build
so many different relationships through
your report but yeah
pepper do you want to add a question
do you want to throw one in yeah sure so
Chloe just talk about how you feel about
the label role model we've talked a
little bit about having girls look up to
you but what does it mean to you to have
that label applied to you
um I think you know when I first
was told that you know I was a role
model it was really intimidating because
again it goes back to that theme where I
just felt like I had to be someone that
I wasn't for a really long time in order
to inspire others and um you know over
the past few years I learned that that's
not true and I am honored to be a role
model I'm honored to be somebody that
can set good examples for our future
Generations but um I also want to be
somebody who's just real and authentic
and I want to be able to be vulnerable
and be open about the things I struggle
with because I think that that also is a
great tool for our future generation I
want everyone to know that it's not
always easy that you're gonna fail that
life just isn't fair sometimes and you
need to learn how to handle those
moments of Grace instead of completely
falling apart which I did a lot
um but again just being myself and being
the best version of myself like I'm
going to be honest I still can't
parallel park that's something that I
need to work on but I will try and do my
best and you guys will know when I do it
because I'm going to be very proud of
myself when I get there I think everyone
can relate right you try your best you
go put your best foot forward but we're
only human so you do what you can to
make it I don't even know you could
scratch your rims parallel parking so
now I'm scared like I don't want to do
it anymore no one can really parallel
park that ring so you're fine you're
fine
um Tatiana you said that with each race
you feel as though you're doing
something for the common good can you
elaborate on that
yeah so it's we've come such a long way
in the marathons I am so inspired by all
the women and each um in each sport and
what they're doing you know in
snowboarding and and in soccer
and I feel like if you can bring
equality in sports you can bring back
equality into your own communities and
so for people with disabilities you know
in the marathons
um well it my advocacy started in high
school as I mentioned earlier and I
really wanted to carry that over into
the advocacy in the paralympic movement
and really dive in deep of what the what
the problem was why are we not equal you
know what what is the understanding and
one is to talk about disability that
it's it's not a taboo and two talk about
Paralympics and to talk about my Sport
and to post it on social media and so
once I was starting to able to do that
then
um I was able to you know go into the
each marathons and to really just talk
about our Sport and
um and to talk about what needs to be
done you know in in the marathons we
used to do press conference press
conferences separately wow and so I
remember going to the marathon and I
said I will never or come back to your
race again if we're not equal next year
into the same press conference even
though I won that year and it magically
changed the following years and it's
been just amazing transition you know
with all the athletes together and um
it's the new found respect for each
other it's really become such a great
community and it's been just such a
great transition oh I know that we're
making it when I was out on training on
the track not long ago and the Father
and Son were watching me and the little
boy goes what's that and the dad goes oh
it's a wheelchair racer you know she's
part of the Paralympics and the kid goes
that's so fast I want to be in the
Paralympics and and I know that we're
making it because you know those
discussions are out in the open and um
and he knew like it was a wheelchair
racer and so each marathon it's been
such a blessing and to work on it yearly
and just seeing the progress Earth and
change and the the Olympics are going to
happen here in LA and I want to compete
here and I want to make a Mark here in
La for Team USA but also for disability
community and so we need to take actions
now if we want the Paralympics to grow
if we want more women to be involved in
the Paralympics for for many sports so
I'm excited to see what the future holds
explosion the future is bright okay I
love that thank you ladies for sharing
your stories today thank you for sitting
with us
um everyone please
um
I mean I honestly I think it goes
without saying that only when we talk
with transparency about the triumphs and
the challenges of our experiences is
that's when we can actually Empower each
other and truly grow and continue moving
forward I think you have to talk about
all of it so thank you so much one more
time everyone for Chloe Tatiana
thank you thank you guys
I'm so grateful that I'm able to stand
on other women's shoulder and now that I
was able to break another ceiling I have
others that get to stand on my shoulders
to take whatever I've done even higher a
lot of different ways that a lot of
athletes that have come before us have
continued to fight for quality and it's
kind of ever-changing and it's going to
continue to grow one of my favorite
memories I would definitely say I had to
look to the older ones who paved the way
for me and um stand on their shoulders
because I needed them at that point in
time
we're thankful for that and I'm also
thankful for all of these amazing women
who have picked up that
um
torch if you will and moved it knowing
that you can be a part of something
great that's going to stretch the vision
of others stress to dream the others and
let others know what is possible even
when you think is not possible it is
possible
yes it is possible are y'all having a
good time yes
pepper are you having a good time
absolutely okay let's keep it moving
right now I want to take you back for a
moment because when we know we came
before us we can absolutely figure out
what to do next that's how we're doing
it today so when we listen to the women
who went first the Pioneers the ogs the
game changers we can climb on their
shoulders and build on their legacy to
propel us forward so I've got two
examples let me make sure I get these
numbers right exhibit a
until the early 1980s the longest
distance a woman was allowed to run in
the Olympic Games was 1500 meters due to
the belief that women weren't physically
capable of handling longer runs
that's crazy again yes we're so glad we
don't have to think like that anymore
pepper and I ran a bunch of 1500s before
we got here okay so that's so we got it
we know we could do it
um and in the summer of 1984 the first
women's Olympic Marathon was held right
here in Los Angeles
this is exhibit B for you all
1997. does anyone hear show of hands
know why that year is so important in
basketball any of my Sierra Canyon girls
here
shout it out if you know what that
happened in 97.
what
yes
that was the first season of the WNBA
listen yes clap it up please
it's mind-blowing to think it's only
been 25 years but it's even more
mind-blowing to just see how beautiful
it's growing how many people are coming
out to the games and supporting the WNBA
I watched it since it's been out don't
need to know how old I am but I've been
watching since the beginning
um listen there are so many women uh
before us and you're going to talk to us
about that yeah so let's meet some of
them let's have some of them with us I'm
thrilled to Welcome to the stage a
couple of pioneers of sport our favorite
record-setting Runner who won the first
Olympic women's Olympic Marathon uh at
the 1987 Summer Games right here in LA
and has been a champion for equality and
access to sport for those who have
fought in her footsteps Joe Benoit
Samuelson
[Applause]
and we have a basketball legend
four-time WNBA champ three-time Olympic
gold medalist and style icon who had the
first signature women's basketball shoe
give it up for Cheryl spoons
yes I need water get hydrated are we
ready how you doing I'm doing great good
okay yeah so we can take a seat let's
get comfortable
okay this is for both of you Joan and
Cheryl first of all thank you for being
up here with us today huge fans
um tell us about this famous or
non-famous who was a woman in sports
that both of you looked up to uh as kids
so for me because I'm older than Cheryl
I looked up to Billie Jean King because
tennis was one of the very few sports
that was available to girls and women in
sport back in my day which was way back
when
well
everybody
like this is super cool to be here I'm
excited
anyway
um so I had a couple
so the first one would be Lynette
Woodard being the first female with the
Harlem Globetrotters like I thought that
was the coolest of the cool right like
my ball handling skills weren't like
that so I knew I could never be yelling
at Woodard but I thought that was really
cool but something that was more
realistic for me was my mom had 13
brothers and sisters and at least four
or five of her sisters played softball
so I grew up going to watch my mom play
softball on weekends and just thought it
was like really cool to watch some real
strong women perform on a softball field
and that was my mom's famous to me she
ain't famous for y'all my shoes
so well she is now we know that right
now
um Joan for you that first women's
Olympic Marathon were you aware of how
much of a Pioneer you were in that
moment
um or again where you just focused
solely on that race what goes through
your mind during that time
well I was pretty much solely focused on
the race because only two weeks before
the Olympic trials I had arthroscopic
knee surgery and everybody was counting
me out but that added fuel to my fire
when I was counted out and I
I needed to focus on the race but it
happened so late in the game but it
happened so that was great but I was
thinking and thanking the Pioneers who
preceded me in sport like Roberta Gibb
and Jacqueline Hansen who lives here in
LA and Charlotte Richardson and
um Nikki uh and they're just so many I
can't start naming them all because
these were the woman who really pushed
the barriers for us and as it was said
1500 meter was the longest woman uh
distance a woman could run so 150 000
miles
um and uh two children later and now a
granddaughter I'm still out there trying
to push barriers as I age in the sport
yeah
[Applause]
all right Cheryl tell us what it was
like to play with the first ever WNBA
championship team
oh wow
um no I love pepper first of all Give It
Up
[Applause]
um
I mean I was just blessed to have an
opportunity to play with some of in my
opinion some of the best players that's
ever played the game and to be a part of
the inaugural WNBA season and a part of
the Houston Comets to win the first four
championships in a row was like that's
that's something that just doesn't
happen whether that's male female I
don't really care what sport so for me
to have an opportunity to play alongside
a Cynthia Cooper and Tina Thompson and
Kim pirate
Jeanette Arcane like I I always try to
embrace every situation every
opportunity and to be a part of such an
incredible group of talented women for
me and to win that first championship I
feel I feel like we set the precedent
and said this is what the WNBA is going
to be about and here we are today
celebrating Title IX and talking about
the WNBA a um it's just such an
incredible honor for me to be a part of
I love that
Joan I know you've said that it's
important to pass the Baton you know to
the next and help each other what are
the best ways that you think that we
especially everyone in this room right
now and everyone watching can really do
that and give back to others
just to be there for her is the most
important thing to be there to support
her to help her live her dreams to keep
the fires burning to develop the passion
and to keep the passion and just to give
them advice as they need advice and I
look at the gazelles and the peppers and
The Chantels that are coming up through
the ranks now and they're the ones who
keep me in the game they inspire me
because there's nothing more important
there's no more valuable resource than
the Youth of today especially the girls
absolutely awesome
um Cheryl similar question to you
obviously being out there on the court
it's it's about you know everybody out
there is looking ahead to the next play
um and what's a different way that
generations of women can support each
other through sport specifically
well from
from a lot similar to what Joan said the
fact that we're here today
um and all of these incredible women are
here and we're on this stage first of
all it's because of Title IX right
without Title IX we're probably not here
having this conversation but I just
think it's important that we always look
to others like we always look to men to
back us and support us but I think it
honestly starts with women like we have
to support each other and even if it's
not a sport that you play or even if you
don't play sports at all like I think
it's really important that we continue
to support women and and we show up for
women in whatever way we can and we
continue to have that conversation we
have that conversation about who we are
what we're about why it's important that
we support women and I would love to be
here 50 years from now dang I might not
be y'all I'm gonna be 100 I won't be but
you will be but uh I don't know about
that either but I just think moments
like this right us having this
conversation in this dialogue and then
you have all these young women in this
room these women will be sitting here
um 50 years from now and and I think
it's important that we continue to talk
about it and just support each other
is it it's got to be remarkable for the
two of you again being the first of
doing something in your career
um to see where we are today is it does
it do you think about that in the very
moment like how many times a day does
that go go through your mind like wow I
was a part of something so special
and look how far it's come
well I think about how blessed and
fortunate I was to be in the right place
at the right time to have strong women
lead me to the threshold of what I was
able to do here in LA and afterward if
it hadn't been for those Pioneers for
those brave souls I wouldn't be here
with the Cheryl and by the way I played
JV basketball and I warmed the bench
most of the time but that developed
strength so what I would say to all the
young girls here is not only to believe
in yourself and live your dreams but to
play the sport of the Season until
you're 14 years old because the skills
you'll develop in those other sports
will help you as you find your own
passion and work on developing those
skills in that particular Sport and I
just can't say that loudly enough but we
need to support our girls in an array of
activities and balance is the most
important thing we can offer to these
young girls yep absolutely
too bad do you guys all agree with that
yes
[Applause]
um I'll I'll ask this last one since we
we have you know time moving on us right
now
um what do you think needs to actually
happen I know you said we sometimes look
to people look to men to like let's get
support but you said the women need to
be there but what do you want to see in
women's sport to make it more Equitable
in the future what could specifically be
done
well I mean I think the first thing that
comes to mind for everyone is pay right
equal pay so I I I'm happy that I can
sit here today and say it's happened in
women's soccer right and so hopefully
it's going to continue to happen in
every other sport but I I I'm just a
firm believer that you control what you
can control you can't control how much
money you get paid right so for me I
just think the the product right like
your brand like to every woman in here
you are your own brand and like how do
you want to present that brand how do
you want to Market that brand and I
think now with the whole new nil and all
those things I think it's just a matter
of time before we as women are finally
getting what is due to us
hopefully yes it's gonna happen oh it's
happening
listen I hope you all have felt so
inspired
um by these two ladies up here I know I
am I'm in shock I tried to like say hi
to both you when I first walked in I was
like let me not fan girl right now
um but thank you
challenge out there to the network so
that when we turn on the TV or we turn
on the radio we're looking for guy
Sports and we're seeing women's and
girls sports on TV
um I think that's that needs to happen
absolutely
yeah
everyone thank you ladies both everyone
please another round of applause for
Cheryl and Joan thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
so I love my coach she's very blunt and
honest which is why I love him
um he's definitely told me to just suck
it up and go do it and I did
it's something I feel like that a bliss
is where all is all we have genuine
relationships when you have people that
really truly want the best brother
oh okay we're gonna do something we're
gonna have a little bit of fun not that
we're not we are having so much fun but
I want to try something with all of you
so I hope you participate are you ready
pepper yeah let's do it okay so I want
everyone to trust me and close their
eyes
okay are your eyes closed
okay no cheating
now think about all the coaches that
you've had throughout your life it could
be someone in your family a teacher at
school someone who shows up for your
team every single week
then I want you to focus in on who has
had the most positive impact on your
life
are you thinking of them
okay now really focus in on how they
made you feel think about those moments
that you exchange with them
I'm gonna bet you felt confident
inspired included
probably like you can do anything
okay thank you for trusting me you can
open your eyes now
I'm going to ask pepper do you want to
share who you were thinking of yeah
absolutely so this person is here in the
audience today my mom
um she has been my softball coach for
her past three seasons and I've loved
every minute of having her as my coach
she is supportive and she is pushing us
and our team has certainly got better
she's been with me and tried to help me
through the highs and lows of my play
and I'm just so grateful for having her
as my host
hi Mom
I love that bond that you two share was
anyone else thinking of their moms or
their friends or family you guys were
all yeah okay it's nice that we have
those people in our lives listen amazing
coaches have the power to change how we
feel about ourselves whether it's just
as a human being walking this planet or
in sport but the problem is at all
levels there's currently a lack of
female coaches only 24 of youth coaches
in the U.S are females and many of those
coaches don't even receive formal
training which is crazy when you think
about it because women and girls we
support each other like nobody else and
we love to cheer each other on and we
like to see each other succeed right and
here to discuss the power of a
transformational coach and why we need
more women in these roles is journalists
and founder of online women's sports
platform highlighter where we are
broadcasting this event today give it up
for Ari Chambers
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
joining her as Defender for Angel City
FC the first Native American to play in
the nwsl and one of sports illustrated's
new and next based on the nwsl Madison
Hammond
[Music]
and lastly founder for the Center for
Healing and Justice through sport a Nike
social and Community impact partner who
is doing critical work with coaches to
give them the tools they need to help
kids but especially girls heal and
Thrive through playing sport Megan
Bartlett
foreign
all right ladies tell me in your opinion
what is the one essential quality a good
coach needs
I'm just comfortable right now very nice
you know pepper I originally would say
empathy and I still think that that's a
super essential quality to have as a
coach to be able to relate to your
players and empathize with what they're
going through but I think that now in
this day and age as you see the Next
Generation coming up it's it's
flexibility knowing when to change
yourself being open-minded and and being
able to be relatable and just this
generation and not just stay in your old
ways so empathy and flexibility I know
you said one but two
I think for me it's creating a system
and an environment that people can buy
into and believe in I think that's
really important and piggybacking off of
the idea of empathy you know being able
to relate to your players on and off the
field creating relationships with them
in order to maximize their potential and
get the best out of them
wow it's hard to go third those are such
good examples
for me I think it's a lot like what um
what Ari said uh for me the sort of
combination of flexibility and empathy
is curiosity
um I think too often we assume athletes
are all one size right and one side and
we can coach them all the same way and
we really have to think about
their unique needs who they are as
people encouraging them to bring their
whole Humanity to sport instead of
saying that part you have to leave at
the door that part's not welcome here
um and so for me it's making sure that
coaches are curious about
who their athletes are what they need
where they come from what they're going
through
and that's the foundation of building
those meaningful relationships yeah and
Megan just add on to that what is one
thing all coaches should watch out for
when interacting with young people and
especially young women
I kind of feel like the idea that idea
of empathy but also I think when you're
interacting with young women you have to
be able to treat them as athletes and
you know you don't need to handle them
with special care or anything like that
I the best the coaches they got the best
out of me were the ones that pushed me
and you know were able to give me
criticism and feedback because they were
invested in my development and I think
those were the coaches that I look back
on when I was younger and those are the
ones that got the best out of me and
helped me level up so that I could get
to where I am today
I think it's a matter of meeting the
athlete where she is where they are
um a lot of times older Generations I'm
guilty of being one of them look at
younger people and feel this like oh do
you have a sense of entitlement but it's
not that they want better for the girls
game for the better for the women's game
and just being able to be open to that
and so looking at this athlete as this
is my this is I'm responsible for this
person's development and growth and I
want what's best for her or them and so
I think that's where we're around we
need to make sure that coaches see the
athletes as humans knowing that the
development is not only their
responsibility within sport but also in
their life as well because I saw my
coach just as much as I saw my mama
growing up right so I just want to make
sure that the coaches know like if you
can be that influential figure in your
athlete's life and and just look to her
or them as you know somebody you are
responsible for even if it's three hours
one time a week if it's three hours
every day a week just make sure you're
touching that athlete in a way that is
critical to their you know growth over
the years
yeah and I think one thing we want to
watch out for and make sure coaches
are are open to is like coaches have to
be willing to grow themselves right and
you're setting such a standard for
lifelong learning if you're willing to
reflect on your own behavior reflect on
what you're good at reflect on what
you're not good at apologize when you
screw up right no coaches I know have
ever screwed up ever but
um but being willing to say I was wrong
and I'm going to try and do better next
time what a lesson for young people if
you can do that well and I want to like
pause because I'm looking at all the
girls and
um the young athletes out here in the
audience and you have an open line of
communication with your coach so there
should be a healthy balance of like hey
I need this from you and then the coach
listening to you and being comfortable
enough to open up to the coach like hey
I'm feeling really bad today I might not
make my time I stop being lazy I'm just
mentally not there and we're living in a
world that's really really difficult
right now and so we have to find comfort
in what we we're passionate about you
know I see a lot of young basketball
players out there if you found love in
the game communicate with that with your
coach be like hey I love this game so
much today sucks today sucks but I'm
gonna make it through for you for my
team but just know I'm just not myself
right now yeah
I love that communication is big and
being able to feel that you know trust
with the person as well
um so what are some easy ways we can all
get into a coaching mindset to help
support younger girls and the women in
our lives because again those are all
great great qualities that a coach
possesses so what can we do
so one of the things that I think is
really important or sort of a norm that
we have to break in sport is that
typically we coach The Way We Were
coached and even though that might have
worked for us
it doesn't mean that we can turn around
and do that exact thing for everyone
we're we're coaching um so I think again
it goes back to this flexibility this
empathy this curiosity about who our
athletes are and really saying yes that
was my experience but other people have
other experiences and we really need to
we really need to be thoughtful about
the way that we you know the doing the
same thing for everybody is sort of a
thought of as Fair
um but it's it's not what kids need
right different kids see different
things and that's actually the best way
to develop young people
put yourself in her shoes and her their
shoes and just see the the it's not
monolithic their experiences aren't
monolithic and so whenever you're
approaching your young group of athletes
or even not young group athletes
um put yourself in their shoes and see
what you would want out of that coach
and say like hey this this style is this
way this style is this way this style is
this way and and accordingly
I like that
all right all right you're all about
shouting out women's sports Excellence
as a Storyteller how do you think we can
use our words to lift each other up
open space for
the people's stories that's what it is
it's it's more about allowing people to
occupy the space as they want to occupy
it instead of
um let me force a narrative so I uplift
women by being the amplifier of women I
see my girls in the audience who love
them shout out to May for the W
um but just knowing that I can like see
what they're doing see their grind and
be able to open up space and be like hey
let me retweet y'all or eventually who
like let me let me speak to you on your
on your panel or you know other teams
other athletes have never got their
stories heard and are just able to
create that space that you can just
really say hey talk to me about you
right I don't I don't need to say
anything I don't need to say much but
here's the space to be able to be
uniquely yourself and I'm not going to
stop you from that so sometimes the best
empowerment and amplification is
allowing somebody to be themselves
I like that absolutely all right Madison
coaching doesn't have to be all about
just one person as a soccer player and a
member of a team how do you support the
other women around you with coach-like
techniques so being in a team
environment I feel like we have an
opportunity to always coach each other
and it's not just about what we do on
the pitch like there are times where I
mean here at Angel City we sell out
games so you literally can't hear they
do yeah
but literally I'll be talking to my
Defender next to me and I'm like well I
can't they can't hear me and so I think
when I think about how you coach it's
through action and not just words and
that carries in how you're a teammate
off the field like I have a lot of
teammates who are entrepreneurs have
businesses you know to ours Point
amplify them on Twitter but it's showing
up for your teammates if they have an
event being there it's you know the fact
that honestly I'm gonna shout out Marcus
rashford here the fact that he's here
you know supporting a women's event it's
like he's an international Superstar and
that
oh
that in itself is doing the work and you
know not just being not just talking the
talk and so for me it's when you want to
be a coach you know just amongst your
peers it's being able to follow up your
words with action and Joshua from
Madison and her game yeah come out to
the games whatever you need just let me
know
all right and Megan you have years of
experience working with coaches and
young people and you're doing
transformational healing centered work
with coaches across North America tell
us why nothing heals like Sport and
maybe give us a little insight to how
crucial the work that your organization
is doing and has been for engaging girls
in sport
uh thanks member
um
yeah so we believe really strongly that
sport has the power to do so many things
and one of those things that we don't
pay a huge amount of attention to is
that it has the opportunity to help
young people heal from the impact of
trauma and adversity and it's because
sport is this really unique combination
of three of the things we need the most
when we experience adversity when we've
experienced trauma when we live through
really chaotic things one is
relationships and we've obviously talked
about that a ton both the relationships
you have with adults who help make you
feel safe but your teammates too right
what Madison was talking about the
second is you get to move your body
right we've this pandemic made a lot of
people sit behind computers a lot more
than they should have
and in order to really help
get the adversity out of your system you
need to move your body change the
biochemistry of your brain in order to
recover and then the last thing is that
we sometimes when we experience trauma
or adversity or live through two and a
half years of a pandemic we think that
the opposite of that overwhelming stress
is no stress right we want to wrap
everybody up in bubble wrap and hope
nothing bad ever happens to them again
when being harmed more right it might
keep us from harm it won't actually help
us heal because the opposite of
overwhelming stress is not no stress
it's little doses of stress it's the
right kind of stress that we that builds
resilience right and if we do that in
the right way and controlled moderate
and predictable stresses which is
playing sport right which is learning
new skills in sport then we have the
opportunity to build the resilience we
need when we're facing those bad things
in other parts of our
so nothing feels like sport because it
puts all of that together in one package
and that's really special all right
pepper I know we're at time I just want
to just insert myself with this note to
coaches out there it is so important to
bring your children to bring your
athletes to these these games right I'm
looking at Madison I'm like she's like
have you been to Angel City game I'm
like no girl I gotta go okay I'm in the
east coast but I have been to a Gotham
game there's 26 years of the WNBA brim
together 12 cities to choose from y'all
are in La I'm assuming y'all can make it
down to Staples I have no idea but
crypto I'm sorry crypto but
make your way out to a game if you can
no matter what sport no matter what
league
um I saw a girl get her shoes signed by
Cheryl swoops the legend Cheryl swoops
that's what matters it's showing that
you know I can see her right in front of
me she's so available and accessible to
me but I can also acknowledge her
greatness and I can see it on the court
and you know Cheryl I grew up watching
right and now she's she's right there
for me so I have a path to sport through
my um visibility into women's sports you
all out there you're in such a unique
position where you've never had to live
without a WNBA you've never had to live
without the effects of Title IX though
we have so far to go
y'all can really make the strides to
intentionally put yourself in places
that you can see your future into so
please please coaches get your kids to
the WNBA against the nwsl games the phf
games to any game that you can and and
all those that are younger out there
that don't want to pursue it um
professionally there's power in playing
so just make sure Nike always says if
you have a body you're an athlete right
so just make sure that you play until
you can't play no more John is over here
still running 17 miles a day Lord just
knows to help her because I can't do it
but but just make sure you continue
playing and if you want to actively
pursue it see somebody in the field that
you want and model model that work ethic
I'm not going to say model that game
model that work ethic to them so that's
all I got to say I'm done
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank you
stop all right that everything you guys
just said absolutely opened my eyes to
the importance of coaching and if
anybody out there if you're interested
in coaching at any level would be
amazing if you join Nike and the Center
for Healing and Justice through sport
for a coaching girls workshop on July
13th further details are at chjs.org
thanks for plugging that pepper
I really do hope to see many of you
there to bring the importance of
coaching girls to life with some deeper
insight and practical tools to be part
of the change and there's still a lot of
change we have to do Title IX helped
white Suburban girls get more access to
sport we have a lot of room to grow in
getting girls from different communities
black girls latinx girls indigenous
girls girls from the lgbtq community
access to sport in the same way so we
got 50 more years let's get going yeah
let's get going I'm about to go
all right everybody please show some
love for Ari Madison and Megan
thank you ladies
it's not just for uh the material thing
or the the gifts and the accolades it's
for the joy of the games just surprising
just wanting to be the best wanting to
be a competitor on all levels and
wanting to win I think that's something
that comes from within and wanted to be
the best that I could be at all times
watching other women do what they do at
their best
[Music]
action
s of others wins as if they were our own
when one of us wins we all win
[Applause]
can we repeat that yeah when one of us
wins all of us win yeah it absolutely
it's true all right sadly everybody
would come to our last session of the
day and it's why we're all here why we
celebrate women's achievements in sports
because we all know the power is for it
brings us together it allows us to
thrive Sports isn't only about
competition because it brings us joy
Sports gives us access to confidence and
helps us to take that confidence into
other parts of our lives when we build
friendships with teammates and
relationships with coaches we build
self-esteem off the court and when we
show up to attract me we can more easily
show up to class and when we know we can
confront a head-on tackle on the soccer
field we know we can better confront
personal hardships in short sport can
change our trajectory in life for our
last conversation today we're going deep
into that joy and the opportunity Sports
brings us because that's why we're all
here right right yeah
I'm sad this is our last one but I'm I'm
hyped yeah this is we're gonna we're
gonna kick it off here we go okay so
let's please give a big warm welcome to
six time National Boxing Champion and
World Boxing Council amateur Champion
Chantal Navarro
[Applause]
and the first athlete to declare they
would play beach volleyball exclusively
in college and winner of three AVP
tournaments Sarah Hughes
[Applause]
let's get comfy okay I like these kicks
I've been staring at everyone's shoes
Okay obsessed so let's talk about this
this is a question for for both of you
um how does Sport bring you Joy
okay
um boxing brings me so much joy in many
different things from competing to
winning not so much losing literally
sucks but um what brings me the most joy
in my sport is that it's a male
dominated Sport and that I get to
represent the female boxers and the
females in the sport that brings me so
much joy and inspires me to work so hard
yeah and for me playing beach volleyball
just waking up every day knowing how to
get to pursue my dreams is unbelievable
and not only that my sport takes me all
over the world so I've built friendships
everywhere and I've met so many
different people and experienced so many
different cultures and it's amazing
I want to talk about how sport boxing
for you Chantal specifically how has
that really changed your identity or
shown who you are because I've watched a
lot of videos of you just like all the
other women here I've seen the training
that you go through how does that kind
of shape who you are today well it's
shaped me into such a hard worker and to
be so dedicated to whatever it is it
doesn't matter what it is it could be
non-sports related but it has made me in
um into such a prideful person into what
I'm carrying behind me which is my
legacy and to represent the females in
my family because
um like I said before it's male
dominated and um yeah I have mostly all
of my cousins guy cousins doing the
sports so and I'm the only female in my
family that has carried on my legacy
um and then for Sarah this question is
for you beach volleyball how did that
change actually the trajectory of your
life and where you are today yeah I mean
it's changed my life so much I started
playing beach volleyball when I was
eight years old and the moment I stepped
onto the court I knew it was something
that I wanted to do for a very long time
and also with that I knew I wanted to
play collegiately and because of Title
IX I had that opportunity to exclusively
play beach volleyball in college and not
have to go to the indoor route and for
me it was a very new sport at the time
and some people thought I was crazy for
you know believing in this Sport and
taking that opportunity when many people
thought it was going to fail but for me
I had so much passion and I really truly
believed in the sport and I took it and
now it's you know one of the fastest
growing NCAA Sports and some schools
even offers up to six scholarships per
team so being able to pave that path for
young girls to play the sport they love
in college is amazing
absolutely we know you both really give
your all to your training and to your
dreams how is that commitment to turning
up helped you thrive in other parts of
your lives
you could go first for me specifically
uh Sports is just so amazing I think it
teaches you so many different things how
to set goals how to achieve those goals
but something that volleyball gave me is
you know I mentioned I played
collegiately and through my academics I
got such a great education I was able to
get a undergrad degree in business and
then I went on and got my masters in
entrepreneurship and those degrees and
that knowledge has helped me today in my
career and I know it's going to help me
afterwards when I'm done playing sports
and as for
um
boxing
um
something that I have carried on from
boxing into my normal life there um is
just the dedication and the
determination from boxing and how how
good my morals have been since I've been
starting boxing like my goals my um like
my goals in school like I just um
finished graduating
um High School yeah last week yeah thank
you
um and and that process for me was very
hard because of all of the traveling
that I do um and something that brings
me so much joy other than my sport is my
family my friends because I'm surrounded
by so many great people and that are
like so supportive of what I do no
matter what it is
yeah we're going to talk about Joy
outside of the sport is it easy for you
to find Joy outside of the sport I know
you're saying family but you love it so
much and both of you are at the top of
your game is it constantly on your mind
or do you let yourself take a little
break to live life for a second well um
boxing is always on my mind no matter
like no matter what it is no matter
where I am it's like when is my next
competition when am I gonna get ready
for my next fight um it's just boxing is
all I do boxing is my lifestyle it is a
lifestyle because you have to put your
all in boxing or in this sport you will
get hurt so yeah yeah it's important
yeah I mean it is it's I feel like it's
so intertwined our Sport with who we are
but I do think it really is important to
take some time and to enjoy life with
family and friends I mean for me family
brings so much joy to my life and
knowing that they support me and will
watch me at all hours of the night to
play is unbelievable so that really
brings me a lot of Joy are they watching
right now too or are they here do you
want to say hi Hi family
um for both of you and I'm sure anyone
here in this room we can agree on that
as women in sports sometimes Society
tells you that it's unladylike to be
ambitious or you know you shouldn't be
thinking a certain way how do you
specifically drown out those voices
because clearly that's not true you can
do whatever you want and hold tight onto
what you want for your future goals
go ahead yeah I mean I just truly
believe and you have to go after what
you want and I think that's so important
don't let anyone ever tell you you can't
pursue your dreams go after everything
and anything you want to pursue and in I
think in sports especially there's going
to be a lot of positive and they're
going to be a lot of negatives not
everyone is going to like you but that's
okay you have to be okay with that
because you are on your own path and
you're carving your own way so I think
it's just really important to surround
yourself with the right people and block
out the other negative influences in
your life and just keep going after what
you want
like what Sarah said to block out all of
the negativity and surround yourself
with the right people and especially if
you're a role model for these little
girls that wanted especially boxing that
want to come up in boxing that want to
try boxing you have to be inspiring um
because you're a female and it's so much
harder for us
absolutely pepper are you into boxing
I don't know I do I just got my black
vote for Taekwondo stop it yes
congratulations
[Applause]
I think we're learning something yeah
are you enjoying karate or Taekwondo
yeah it's it's a lot of fun it's a great
way to like be disciplined and learn to
express yourself so I love that
absolutely ladies thank you so much
continue doing everything that you're
doing and thank you for being amazing
role models to to all of us everyone
Chantel and Sarah
[Applause]
ladies Chantel actually I lied don't
leave yet come on back stay on the stage
for a moment because we've been talking
about how much uh Sports can bring us
joy so we're going to take a second to
be about that we've got some special
guests in the audience who are
representing the future we've got
Giselle Thompson all the way from
England and uh Manchester United's
Marcus rashford so everybody give them a
round of applause
foreign
and we do want to take a moment to get a
little bit of that Joy going on up on
the stage so I'm gonna ask
um everybody to come out and have some
fun with me
we have to stand up right yeah let's
stand up are you ready for this
everybody should be clapped and bring
everybody out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
come on down come this way come this way
yeah we've got space uh pepper you're in
front okay you're our teacher you're our
coach today you're the coach
all right everybody
yeah yeah toy
I don't know all right so I'm gonna show
a combination of the sports that I play
and then I'm gonna have starting all the
way down at Joan we're just gonna go
down the line and have everybody do a
little movement that represents their
Sports so I'm gonna go ahead and start
if you want to go after me then we can
go to Joan
all right
um yeah you can go here so this is my
movie
Joe
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my God I stole her moves
wait come up here pepper all right I
gotta get in front of here everyone
thank you for joining us today for her
rise 2012
thank you to all of you for being so
incredible today being inspirational for
all of us it was a good day we want to
thank you all for celebrating 50 years
right pepper of Title IX and 50 years of
Nike championing sport for all athletes
and join us as we Blaze the trail and
redefine sport for the new generation
for the next 50 Years everybody please
show your love to all our guests for
such honest uh awesome game changing
conversations to push us all forward
all right so we've got Chloe Kim Tatiana
McFadden raylen Turner R.A Chambers
Madison Hammond Megan Bartlett Johan
Benoit Samuelson Cheryl swoops Chantal
Navarro and Sarah Hughes everybody Give
It Up
okay and remember everyone progress is
never done so let's continue to rise
together thank you Los Angeles
[Applause]
my dream for sport over the next 50
years is that diversity and inclusion
becomes so commonplace that we don't
have to talk about it in the same
gravity that we do today allow them a
safe space where they feel like they can
continue pushing themselves and no dream
is too big for them first it means you
know the same Equity it means equal
opportunity
and it means equal investment into sport
um you know as you would do them then
just do the same for women now we belong
and have a seat at the table just like
everybody else
her rise because she is never done